no more can I talk about games real
quick yeah what's up for tonight's
season - we don't we like chat about it
we don't [ __ ] know because we didn't
play it and we're not gonna play it I'm
bringing up something that is semi
related to that two things one Lady Gaga
tweeting at ninja who are you it's the
most Hollywood like hey list
out-of-touch thing I've ever said he's
[ __ ] awesome
not even like doesn't even ask her
manager or someone around her doesn't
ask anyone just zero shame who are you
and ninja replies ask Drake oh yeah just
oh damn that yeah God leave it to him to
[ __ ] up something like get you high
[ __ ] up big time then do you [ __ ] up
big time [ __ ] up big time people who
[ __ ] up big time yeah and isn't that
does every news outlet big news somebody
[ __ ] up big time everyone that's what
that is
you [ __ ] up big time I made fun of
angel mammy big time
she's a queen and you [ __ ] up big time
Cody you've done [ __ ] and you done
[ __ ] goofed and up big time goofed it
you goofed and you [ __ ] up you [ __ ]
up and you [ __ ] down left and right
big time Big Time the one so the thing I
hate right now a ninja you [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it all up second one there who
are you who are you you know what's
funny to me there is is like picturing
her just innocently trying to do
research on the eSports yeah I just like
sitting there like this just not getting
it at all so honey people apparently go
to stadiums to watch I know crazier than
that people sit at home and watch other
people play video games what is this
world coming to
there's this guy named ninja he's
apparently you know what I'm just gonna
tweet at him
I've had enough are you and see what he
says as big as I am I should be able to
figure this out yeah no problem
yeah you think you'd ask anyone else in
your life or just even a DM
but publicly who are you so much funnier
who are you TM yeah DM from Lady Gaga
just saying who are you oh I'm a popular
video game player oh cool
well I'll just wanted to say what's good
what I could see it as condescending to
the [ __ ] are you yeah do you think you
are I think you are I'm Lady gaga
you good yeah you throw out your c57 l-3
big back pain energy right now yeah you
don't [ __ ] up yeah I gotta stop saying
that [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up big time no
no the other thing I want to bring up
was this this is really what I care
about is Guy Fieri tweeting out a custom
[ __ ] skin it's like made by epic so
this image and it's a [ __ ] fortnight
skin of Guy Fieri with flavortown in the
background oh that's sick and he goes
where we drop in ninja now I hate that
this is what I hate about ever get
stopped trying to weave I get that it's
smart and all this and that such on a
weave pop culture in the games yeah game
should be an escape you know I mean yeah
there should be some [ __ ] that's like
I'll I go into this thing and I forget
about everybody else I don't want to go
into [ __ ] fortnight and see there's
like 5,000 Guy Fieri's yeah Guy Fieri's
and products and [ __ ] you yeah next time
you know looking marshmallow yeah it
smart if you go to go to marshmallow
Bobby Flay town where they [ __ ] do a
speedy speedy cook-off to a brand new
EDM music exclusively made for fortnight
yeah you're like I'm just watching TV
yeah that's that's what I'm around yeah
it's pretty soon eh they just scale away
like all the fighting they made the map
super huge yeah yeah everything's a big
[ __ ] ad yeah just and design like in
like little billboards to the shittiest
form of advertising just running around
looking at billboards all day ad space
in a [ __ ] VR yeah an AR whatever the
[ __ ] it's gonna be a thing no it already
is it there yeah they turn all the gas
stations like in the shell like
everything becomes branded this season
all the cars are made by Ford [ __ ] me
they're all [ __ ] Ford Flex is Energy
ta having those radio stations yes that
was sick
that was sick they played all original
[ __ ] right no like they they like went
and like I mean they did get original
[ __ ] like they either licensed music or
people made music for GA yeah but like
they made entirely fake radio shows like
that yes like that's so cool yeah that's
that's dope like that's immersive that's
it's real I don't [ __ ] with this goofy
like what if we yeah
what can put Sandra Bullock in fortnight
what can Lady Gaga skin gonna be next
oh that's a hundred percent yeah so
tweet at ninja next week hey where we
drop an inch yeah also who are you I
still don't know using Ninja is such a
spit in the face like everyone was
actually good at games - I know million
other dudes on there infinitely more
entertaining and humble and interesting
it's so weird that he's just like the
face of like [ __ ] video games now
yeah yeah like like pop culture video
game pick the worst one it's so weird I
mean actually he's not though
he's not the worst good no he's not he's
not the world I mean just like thank God
twenty bajillion dollars can't dress
himself with a gun to his head man
the drip is awesome Matt shut the [ __ ]
up
you don't [ __ ] up big time you [ __ ]
up the podcast big time what do you have
to say about the new for ninth season
give a [ __ ] I don't give it all right
let's not hating on Ninja for five
minutes straight we should sound envious
yeah [ __ ] stinks with all his money
and is no but it is kind of funny how
he's the face of like why the [ __ ] is he
still going on Jimmy Kimmel and stuff
like that it's no like I understand at
the height of his popularity when they
had like a hundred thousand people
watching his streams yeah but now it's
not even close to that now I know so why
is he still going on these like I know
mainstream TV shows and stuff like that
it's because they like chosen him as
like this is the guy that's that's that
we're gonna push and get like boomers to
accept videogames as like a real sport
there's a real part of pop culture and
all he's the one that's doing it and all
the Middle America looks it was like
look at him I'll salamander built ass
with the colored hair gamers are weird
get [ __ ] Nick mercs man get Daquan
get edges
yeah who's like actually endearing yeah
and like genuine yeah I said they picked
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] dude and they
got him saying an Old Town Road my god
yeah why did he go on the masked singer
I don't know dude
I have no [ __ ] clue a part of me kind
of respects it like a part of me kind of
respects the fact that whoever his team
is is making moves oh yeah they're
making it have a sling to like keep him
in the public eye yeah which is kind of
what you need to like be successful
percent if someone's constantly got
[ __ ] let's just do this weird show at
the same time it's like there's no
integrity like what where are you
anymore yeah yeah are you ninja the
gamer or are you ninja the masked singer
who goes on Jimmy Kimmel and drinks Red
Bull does the pawn pawn dancer who the
[ __ ] is Ian whatever man
[Music]